yes hello and welcome to this video bit
of a late start against mr. Yardbird
illa glue bond I've switched on this
recording to be too late but I think
everything's okay so what's going on
here yeah he delayed maybe I can still
they can care for here I can Castle
h5 is not so dangerous they as it is in
many other situations but I still think
it's interesting if you do it simply
does not want to allow me this attack
it's a bit of a shame but it's still ok
as to like this position now this is one
point of the setup
hmm really I understand there that this
Bishop is not really all that great but
it's it looks a bit strange to do this
without having castle ok yeah
and now we're like a 5 which is
attacking it or Mookie aids so stopping
castling 93 and 1994 immediately also as
a move then you might cancel at the end
so let's try this first I might take one
c6 I don't know taking on c6 is
strategically very interesting because
it killed some ammo bishop then is it
very difficult to get get into the game
yeah he plays it he plays it I can
ma'am they have two sets of valid ID em
absolutely any way to bring this bishop
back into the back into the plane
oh I am and that's a very well-known
idea just as a side to lead
yeah I've got Bishop a6 ideas now but
don't know if they do all that much
should be 8
that's quite funky but not not a bad
moment to do it I mean I'm threatening
to take on before I was the idea a
little bit a little bit awkward at this
precise moment for Wired I should have
allowed lightly Bishop takes c6
extremely unpleasant
now I should be able to at least know
this is a good news to get into a
position I wanted to say well when you
have to take with the piece but it's not
not true okay you have to put on the 5mm
and hope that this Bishop at least is
doing something good should contain a
subset achilles piece extremely
ridiculous piece
I don't think he ever wants to wants to
take on a five but at least you can
imagine that I can get something against
against c5 then okay try to double on
the youporn
at least the bishop is cool 25 let the
only thing we are 95s on the cards
it's tough to play if you a bishop down
hoping for king g6 and h5 something like
that but time morning I missed that that
was on a move earlier even but the
position is probably so bad that he can
even give up stuff yeah
we can get good teeth
I'm still that bishop it's driving me
crazy interesting King needs to move a
failing Bishop c5
check catch come to play here somehow
check 96 and position was too bad I mean
it really allowed tons of things that
you shouldn't have allowed but land
resign if you cannot play without this
Bishop I mean the computer might give me
an advantage after you run the distance
it's still tough to play I mean you have
this dead piece and I hope the hm-hm
cow maybe now this is this is just a bit
of a shame you know because this is not
good at all you just have to avoid this
Bishop takes 6m so I mean this I
shouldn't have allowed him oh I have 94
you why because of checkmate I have a
check
ah you know I was just thinking I am I I
still owe jeg ikke that's made checkmate
that's made and then Bishop c6 is of
course crap there that's the dance total
crap I just take the knight take with a
knight next one to six okay so then Buki
eight wasn't a bad move but I can just
do something like that and the white
position doesn't make much sense really
with the bishops sorry with the bishops
have the night show and you want any -
yeah but this this this is now extremely
uncomfortable extremely uncomfortable
with the with a dead piece there on b8 I
know that the engine is just sorry this
is a case where the engine does not
understand too
position the bishop is not coming out
ever the white is just extremely better
and our engine wants to take on 85 and
like do it in a technical way yeah it's
just a terrible position I mean he
allowed this this stuff on the kingside
which was completely unnecessary here
butchy one I can still not take this was
unnecessary and okay it might be a
better with Ruby eight and so on it's
still pretty pretty awfulness to play
can much much easier for y to play this
position well yeah okay thanks for
watching guys